a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi e domenica
quindi siamo su happy meals tratto
ragazzi sono raffreddati mi sento la mia
voce e 45 volte sotto il naso totalmente
chiusa che c'è tipo no cioè la password
per aprirlo non fa ridere fa bene
iniziamo sbattiamo cieli del mio
raffreddore l'opera genere spero che mi
passi perché è un casino se no iniziamo
col primo ragazzon coors 6 non so che
cos'è welcome to word un cus seria come
che siete tutti così felici di vedermi
con raffreddore perché voi non ce
l'avete il naso bastardi e voi non vi
ammalate stronzi cosa è successo ciao
ragazzi io le lame non aveva neanche
viste come cazzo è possibile
gli open di tivo tira che gli ha
provveduto padre che incastrato dove vai
stronzo di un figlio cioè non i bagnanti
così chi se ne fotte
non so che cazzo è successo ma memo lato
gli occhi e ti posso pure sopra così
impari a lasciare indietro tuo padre
brutto stronzo lo sa per la vendetta
alla fine ragazzi c'è sempre
cos'è sta roba devo andare no no no no
no si no ma che cazzo va beh forse posso
continuare ad andarci mai non si pedala
sul manubrio è di 8 ragazzi non vi
preoccupate che prima o poi ce la farò
fini questo livello
ve lo giuro comunque ragazzi uno dei
livelli più strani che abbia mai fatto
questo è sicuro
ok sono ancora vivo posso annusarli le
palle da biliardo vai così che cazzo
ragazzi sto livello interminabile tutto
così mio zio fin fine shammah come come
definiti cos'è fatality fatality cosa
non ho fatto nulla
cioè è partito da soli non ho fatto
nulla
grazie grazie ho vinto non si sa come
ragazzi ho vinto ma chi se ne fotte da
river mi sembra il nome di un film che è
il protagonista di sto film è di andy
perfetto ragazzi è di non ha mai fatto
un film ma come debutto mi sembra
incredibile chiesto pesce ok pesci si ma
si mangiano le farfalle non lo so da
quando ma da oggi per ci mangiano le
farfalle bene così perché ci sono pesci
che salta misto a livello francese il
padre di uk gesto pescando e la giornata
non è vero a voi ragazzi mi son [ __ ]
la canna da pesca
cos'è perché c'è una scimmia che cazzo
ci fa una 5 mia foto dura capisca ma che
stronza cos'è sticazzi dell'amira
complimenti
cioè io allora
fondato un caravan che ho finito così
cioè ragazzi pesci che mangiano farfalle
padre di duke che pesca scimmie che
fottono canne da pesca c'è ma cosa cazzo
che hanno giocato ma boender sword non
facciamo finta di niente
io non cos'è con nonno ciak ma ragazzi
proviamoci lo stesso anche se non vedo
un cazzo non ho jacques checa come cazzo
fatta a salvarsi uk ma che culo chat
cazzo di culo
ok perfetto abbiamo no perché non poteva
salvarsi così soprattutto gli occhi poi
ma ci siamo steve ma anche su cui che
cazzo ci fai appeso togliti dalla mia
sedia
se questo si può chiamarsi sedia gli
skate the box ragazzi proviamoci con il
con indiana con il d'ora indiana brutto
stronzo fai il tuo lavoro
sì ma stai calmo non pensavo così in
fretta sinceramente va bene facciamo voi
non avete visto non la fate finta di
niente
gli over su chuck norris questa devo
fare ragazzi fra vj versus chuck norris
questa è bella prova a sorpassare chuck
non non puoi sorpassarmi sono chuck
norris
ah sì bene io sono fuori j ok io
smaterializzato la testa senti chuck non
è
non era mia intenzione ai ciak si buono
con me
facciamo così tu mi fai passare e io ti
do questo buonissimo barattolo di
favella te lo sto dando di mia spontanea
volontà è accettalo che è un sofà
sticazzi gli addominali ed non pensavo
ci lavorassi così è aspettate madonna
cool rock swing questa devo fare con ed
i ragazzi
vai così è di farmi vedere al contrario
c'è ma da quando esistono i suoi e si è
rock swing al contrario vai ed crooks
ragazzi sono sono riuscito a non morire
come cazzo ho fatto raga non lo so
speriamo finisca qui livello si è chiuso
assurdo 99 per cento impossible by così
fammi vedere steve fammi vedere se il
primo senza tv cosi di mio zio due
secondi 93 ragazzi due fottuti secondi
nuovo record personale hanno veramente
ragazzi devo tenere il record che si
lamenti devo fare così grande e coin
prendi la moneta cosa è stato così vai
steve lo steve austin e di raggiungerla
già puoi fare ce la puoi fare
che cazzo di anguilla sto uomo ragazzi e
dovrei fare un attimo perché so che non
ci riuscirò mai più tipo togli della dal
culo
raga ma chi cazzo fai ci sembra che stia
ballando miyake testata bruttissima sono
ancora vivo non so come best herbert
hoover il miglior casco di sempre
quasi a devizioni samnium
alla rimonta ci della signora nel terzo
piano che cazzo ti butti dalla finestra
cioè 6 6 6 secondi ciao ragazzi io io
sto casco sarà anche il migliore vi
sapranno lo metterei mai giusto perché
c'è scritto 666 comunque va bene
rainer pioggia di frecce cos'è sta roba
ragazzi con babbo natale questa è la
faccio con babbo natale che potevo
uscire vai così ho letti di merda non
formale stringete i denti ragazzi non
fate cadere i regali che per i bambini
sono scontenti è io che cosa vi pago a
fare trainate da slitta pro fischiare le
ragazze è bruttissima che babbo natale
non si è fatto un cazzo
cioè sono tanto gli è grande così grazie
ragazzi e poi si dice che non tratto
bene i miei dipendenti
mi avvio vaia dice poi fare credi in te
al primo tentativo
ce la posso fare ragas stacca distacca
distacca distaccati così
come cazzo fatta rimbalzare col culo
finissima ragazzi andiamo con collo beta
con lo pensava così chi è chi è che devo
uccidere chi a chi devo far male a e
disse di di chi era quella donna con cui
ti vedevi ieri si tradisce mi tradisci
metterò la tua testa sul tavolino dove
tieni le riviste vietato ai minori e se
io becco la tua amante le faccio un culo
ragazzi e si sa cos'è è il team hiker a
lei con la collettiva ed è vi è anche un
figlio illegittimo ragazzi c'è liuc che
cazzo ci fa you kiss a livello
vabbè usciamo di qua perché sono liti
familiari che non ci riguardano qui non
importa cheating white cos'è sta roba
raga devo fare press ap aspettate prende
pensato che dovrete televisore vai così
cazzo scusate se vi ha interrotto
continuate pure poi fate finta che non
ci sia
ciao york come tutto a posto ha mangiato
pesante ieri era gradirei riportare ai
livelli fatti per me anche questa
settimana
partiamo dalla garanzia sto punto
impossible per fa vj porta vj off ora lo
leggo por non si sa perché non fatevi
questa domanda puoi scegliere due vie
difficili o facile c'è ma veramente lui
pensa che io scelgo a quella facile ma
stiamo scherzando
a mio zio
[Musica]
beh però vinto paga ce la posso fare
si no [ __ ] non è come cazzo è che
voglio in quella difficile e vinco in
quella facile vabbè ragazzi mi hanno
detto di aver fatto facile perché è
letteralmente impossibile che posizione
è questa
cioè una roba da yoga vero dimmi tu no
vabbè comunque è impossibile fare il
difficile c'è una cosa assurda
però il facile l'ho fatto parra pur
qualcosa quindi va bene così
mille per cento imposto in questo mi dà
ancora che è più impossibile ma
ovviamente questo lo faccio fisso in
salita
un nuovo record 23 st 6 ma neanche
finito l'episodio che non ci ha battuto
perfetto che mai così non ci posso
credere di mx farfa vj questo devo fare
assolutamente fatevi prendere padre luke
baille così mi ispirano scrive cos'è mi
è piaciuta la partenza amico mio
sai come fare un livello che mi piace
bra ma a che livello di merda la propria
ragazza ovviamente scherzavo però è
impossibile fare nomi oddio una forza
oscura mi spinge oltre non lo so che
cazzo mi ha scritto ragazzino non lo so
però vabbè non importa non facciamoci
domande e scendiamo le scale come solo
il padre di yoox a fare mai così questo
questo è impossibile non già farò mai
infatti forse sì forse intorno senza
dubbio all uomo che camminava sulle
acque non si sa come faccio se non la
faccio la merenda di fa vicine cos'è sta
roba favi salute per me il junior karin
walter chuyen feroli tommaso anno
giovanni marco luca diletta hermenegildo
è andrea c'è qualcun altro no perché
mekas come lo scrivo al caso di cenni
usare l'ascia aipav i ricordi lo stronzo
che ti ha potuto la merenda mi ha potuto
la merenda liuc è potuto la merenda e io
neanche lo sapevo
brutto stronzo mangiati questo ragazzi
questo succede a chi mi ruba la merenda
dei ragazzi direi che posso concludere
qui l'episodio come vi ho già detto
detto che hanno fatto che ce ne sono
veramente tantissimi livelli fatti per
me che ancora non ho fatto che lasciato
indietro perché ovviamente sono troppi
ragazzi più avanti ci dedicherò un
episodio soltanto a questi quindi non
preoccupatevi ragazzi se vi do è
piaciuto come al solito ha scelto il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovato
nella descrizione se non ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi non ci rivediamo il prossimo
video bella ragazzi